heads up guys my name is Regina welcome
back to another hazel dev vlog I thought
that I would take things in a very chill
manner today I'm not very chill though I
thought we'd be nice and chill today and
just talk about what I've done in the
past two weeks like a traditional kind
of dev vlog so as most of you probably
know by now because I keep saying it
my goal currently for hazel is to get it
to the point where I can start making
games with it which I mean it's a gay
mansion so that sounds like a pretty
standard goal but especially for kind of
2d and even though hazel dev which is
primarily like the development version
of hazel that I'm working on that
they'll support 3d and we have 3d
rendering in there the workflow for both
2d and 3d is more or less the same at
least when you break it down to the core
components of what makes up patooty in a
3d game workflow like they still need to
be able to for example save and load
scenes and interact with like scripting
languages and do all that stuff entity
component system that's all the same
whether you're working on a 3d game or
2d game
so therefore the engines workflow is
very very very similar so I've gotten to
the point where we have an entity system
in hazel we have C shop in hazel we can
basically more or less put together
pretty complicated games even because by
exposing enough of the C++ code to the
scripting language and by writing some
of your own code in the scripting
language you can actually do quite a
number of things but the problem is that
whilst all this exists in the same in
the editor and can be caught on where
played there's no way of saving it you
open hazel you build your game and you
close hazel and the games gone that's it
there's no there's no way you can
actually save your scene furthermore
since there is no way to save the scene
that you've created inside the actual
like editor there's no way to actually
play the game as a standalone game all
you can do is experience that through
the editor while you're working on it
there's no actual way the runtime can
actually play the game because the scene
only exists within the editor and of
course that's a huge issue so basically
what I did over the last couple of weeks
was created a system for us to be able
to serialize and deserialize scenes as
well as actually hit a play button in
the editor to play the game this one
system is quite large and it ends up
solving both of those problems
on
one hand it lets you actually save a
scene and then load a scene in the
editor so that you can shut down the
editor open it on a new day and continue
working on your scene but it also allows
you to actually play the game because
the scene can then be loaded by the
runtime and played that's a really
important distinction and to be honest I
could spend the next hour talking about
how all of that works and all the little
things to consider that comes from not
only just serializing and deserializing
scenes but also being able to actually
play them in the runtime whilst editing
them in the editor and link that all up
into the scripting language and there's
a lot of stuff and I want to eventually
take you guys on a little bit more of a
technical deep dive onto how how I
orchestrated this entire system and the
amount of time and talk which was quite
a while as well putting all the pieces
together testing everything and it spits
I mean it's pretty much at the point
where I can at least see the end and
it's mostly working and if you want to
see an hour-long discussion about this
just let me know in the comments below
and I'll happily sit here and talk for
ages but for those of you who don't
don't worry this videos not gonna be
that long what I'll do is actually show
you this working in a minute here but
first I want to talk a little bit about
notices in a sponsorship it almost
sounds like a sponsorship doesn't it
first I wanted to talk a little bit
about some considerations when it comes
to an actual scene format and by that I
mean specifically like a file format how
do we actually save a scene what format
are Hazeltine saved in and why so when
it comes to picking a file format
there's there's two major considerations
to make and this is very broad so I
might make a video in the future talking
a little bit more in depth about all of
this just outside of the context of even
a game engine but essentially we have
two different types of files we have a
text file and we have a binary file they
both have their advantages and
disadvantages
binary is extremely fast to the
commutative process it's also extremely
easy to just write out a bunch of binary
data from C++ into a file and also load
it it's dead simple if you have a struct
of data that's just you know kind of all
kind of packed together inside that's
truck none of its kind of directing to
other pointers there are other memory
locations you can just dump that whole
memory to a file and done then you can
load it on any computer you want you
know once you deal with some big in
little-endian problems we'll get all
those you can load it on that
and then just it's just gonna be just
put it into memory and you're basically
done it's super easy to deal with
however humans can't really open that
file and read it that's what text files
come in with a text file you can easily
just open it in notepad and look at the
data there now that does come as a
consequence to the fact that it's hard
for a computer to read if you have to
decipher a string that is a float and
then kind of converted into a float and
go through every field manually and make
sure the values said to the right thing
and can bed into a string and converted
from a number into a string to serialize
it that's a lot of work and that's kind
of difficult and time-consuming for a
computer to do but it's better for
humans so what do you pick for a game
engine and the answer is both on one
hand when you're actually dealing with
the process of producing the game so in
other words you're editing a scene in
the scene editor you want that to be a
text file why because you want to be
able to open it and read it why though
why would I want to read my own level
format in nart pad and the answer is you
probably don't specifically want to read
it in notepad but when you're
collaborating with other people or even
just with yourself and you make updates
to it or if two people are working on
the same scene file when it comes time
to actually consolidate those two kind
of divergent copies you can actually
just merge them using any kind of text
diff tool because everything's in text
so you can clearly see what entities
have been added what transforms have
been changed all of that stuff you can
you can easily iterate it as a human and
decide which parts to take to combine
that and resolve all this conflicts even
if you're working on your own you can go
through your git history or whatever
version control you're using and
actually see what has been changed in
the level it's really easy and it's
definitely not doable if you're using
binary of course you could write a
custom binary tool to do something like
that but that's just overkill so long
story short in the master version of
these files which is what you're doing
while you're actually working on that
level in production you want that to be
a text file however when it comes time
for your game to actually run outside of
the editor perhaps and actually be
distributed and published and shipped
and all of that you want it to be binary
because first of all you don't need
anyone
actually looking at the level in fact
you might even want to protect that but
also you want it to run as fast as
possible and since we don't need any of
the benefits that come with text files
it is a lot better to just have that be
binary it'll be smaller you can compress
it even more mean you can compress text
as well but that will make it not
readable it'll be way faster for the
computer to actually load that and
process that as opposed to if it was a
text file and needs to convert all the
strings into actual into like the right
format so in other words text and binary
both of them are great both of them have
their uses and that's what you need if
you want a good scene system for a game
engine so anyway let's actually go to
hazel now and take a look at what it's
like to kind of put together a scene in
hazel and then maybe save it and load it
again and actually hit play and maybe
something will happen ok so what I've
done here is just opened up hazelnut
which is Hazel's editor and I have not
loaded any scenes at all so what you
have is effectively at the moment a
completely blank canvas you just have a
grid which you can toggle with ctrl-g
and that is pretty much it from there
you can load an environment map to give
it some color and the background in the
sky box and then you can also create
entities inside the scene hierarchy but
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to load an existing scene so I'll
just go file open scene and then I have
one here that I've made called pink
sunrise at the moment the extension is
dot H SC which stands for Hazel scene so
I'll open this and here we have the
scene being loaded in here so this is
just my kind of test scene that I've
been using for a while now that's just
demonstrating different materials being
on different sub meshes we can still you
know move this around as usual and you
can see here we have test entity there's
also an unnamed entity and that's just
more of an internal thing that actually
is like an entity that makes up the
scene itself but inside test entity we
have this actual entity and you can see
it's made up of a name here it's got a
good some kind of unique identifier it's
got a transform it's got a mesh
component and it's got a script
component which links it to a script and
I think at the moment the script will
just continually move it I think in a
certain direction based on what this
speed is so if I set the speed to 1
these variables here by the way I just
public fields written inside the c-sharp
script that just being automatically
exposed so now what can I do
this well at the moment this scene has
no camera so if I hit this little play
button up here to run it we're not
actually gonna see anything so what I'll
do is I'll add a camera I'll right-click
here create empty entity here I have my
empty entity I'll rename it something
useful like camera maybe and then I'll
add a camera component to it now this
stuff is very primitive at this point in
time I literally just slap this in like
yesterday but if I add the camera here I
can set the projection type to
perspective or orthographic which will
give it some different properties here
it's got a bit of default field of view
of 45 which is pretty standard
vertically I can't actually see the
camera in the scene because it's not a
mesh so it doesn't have like a bounding
box or any visual representation in the
future of course it will have some kind
of icon and probably just like a
bounding box or something that shows the
actual projection for Ostin but at the
moment there's no way to actually see it
or really manipulate it I mean I could
translate and rotate it but that's
probably not going to do much maybe I'll
just move it back a little bit but
ultimately what I want to do at this
point is probably hit play and see what
happens so if I hit play it's gonna run
my scene and you can see it's wherever
the camera is if I click on the camera I
can still actually edit it and
manipulate it and do whatever I want
with it here and the scene of course is
playing which is pretty cool if I click
on test and see I can also see the
transform actually changing in real time
I can hit the play button again and it's
gonna stop the scene will jump back to
the editor camera but you can see that
at the moment the scene hasn't all been
reset
that's because anything that happened in
the scene at the moment is actually kind
of stored in the scene because it's all
one scene it's not like when you hit
play it creates a new scene and then
starts everything like that and when you
hit stop it reversed back to the editor
scene they're actually one scene at the
moment which is why you see this whole
movement here so yeah definitely
something that I need to work on because
obviously resetting the scene is
something that is likely going to be
very important now let's say that I
wanted to add another object into the
scene I can create an empty entity here
I can add a mesh component to it I can
load a mesh so I'll load this sphere 1m
mesh here and then I'll zoom out a bit
because it's huge I can scale it down
maybe I'll just put it over here and I
can run my scene again and you can see
we now have a sphere in our scene as
well so that's basically what we've got
inside hazal dev the ability to kind of
play these scenes as well as edit them
it's it's kind of getting there there
are still a lot of features to add and
so many things that I could do and of
course it's having loading thing so I
can save this scene let's save it as
pink sunrise modified or something like
that I'll hit save I'll open the old
scene which is this this is before we
had even a camera or anything like that
and then I'll open my pink sunrise
modified sin and you can see I get back
here and I can do various things I mean
I can even change the environment map to
something like Birchwood 4k maybe a load
of different HDR map I can save that as
pink sunrise modified here and then if I
open being sunrise again will snap back
to where I wasn't if I open the modified
version you'll see that we have the new
environment map and everything basically
has been saved
and I can of course play the scene and
you can see it in my same place okay so
I hang on a minute
okay so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please don't forget to
hit the like button below because it
does help me and this channel are
speaking of helping me out if you wish
you can also help support hazel and my
youtube channel and everything I'm doing
by going to paranal calm for / the
Cherno you'll get access to what you
just saw in the hazel development branch
you'll also get access to weekly live
streams where I work on that kind of
stuff so if you are interested in all of
that and you want to help hazel and me
out then thank you so much for your
support is greatly appreciated
hope you guys are all doing okay and I
will see you soon with a new video
goodbye
[Music]